The Love is Blind backlash and we're not
just talking about the couples some
folks are accusing Kohl's Nick Lachey a
throwing shade at his past marriage hey
it's always better the second time right
cheers Nick's comment and fist bump to
Matt who had also been previously
married seemed aimed at his ex-wife
Jessica Simpson one fan tweeted that did
not sit well with me
[Music]
this process has been hard and there's
been ups and downs Matt's lady Colleen's
body language also concerned fans I did
kind of lose my cool a little bit she
needs to run for the hills because this
guy is controlling at the reunion which
was shot earlier this fall the couple
revealed they had not yet moved in
together nearly a year and a half after
saying I do and E.T has learned SK and
Raven are still dating oh my gosh I'm so
happy for you guys I know but tonight's
most talked about too some xenob and
cold this after producers showed
previously unaired footage which Zen up
claims was an example of coal
controlling her eating oranges are you
about to eat two of those maybe that's
the serving you okay with that you
better save your Appetito the same
divided fans some defending coal in
response to her critics Zenna posted a
lengthy message flippantly writing sorry
20 times before ending with I stand by
everything I said she then turned off
the comments I could have dragged you
foreign